Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update sony online entertainment
developers of h1z1 and planetside 2 has
been sold by sony the sale was announced
this morning by former SOE employees
after the company had been purchased by
columbus nova an investment management
firm based in new york the studio wrote
this means that effective immediately
SOE will operate as an independent game
development studio where we will
continue to focus on creating
exceptional online games for players
around the world and now as a
multi-platform gaming company yes that
means PlayStation and Xbox mobile and
more the company has rebranded as
daybreak game company which the studio
says quote is a nod to the passion and
dedication of our employees and players
it is also representative of our vision
to approach each new day as an
opportunity to move gaming forward super
cheesy good daybreak game studios will
continue to support their current games
and develop new IPs and they say they
quote expect to have even more resources
available to us as a result of this
acquisition so hey planetside 2 for xbox
one could be possible sometime in the
future more gaming news go to gamespot
com / news